hi everyone my name is haidu I am an
associate professor in the human
computer interaction Institute at
Carnegie Mellon University it is my
great pleasure today to speak here and
introduce some of our recent studies and
findings
it is on
okay so human beings are inherently
social animals Our Lives depending on
other humans
and we as humans we form social systems
like groups communities organizations
every day we connect communicate
exchange and work with each other in
Social systems
in the past six decades the Computing
technologies have fundamentally changed
how we interact with each other in
Social systems
I do research in human computer
interaction and social Computing at a
high level I study how the Computing
Technologies and our groups communities
organizations and societies are
co-evolving and transforming each other
in the process
foreign
groups Community or organizations the
abilities to understand the socially
relevant human behavior is critical to
success of any of these social systems
for example in one-on-one conversations
two people have to understand each
other's intense behaviors in order to
coordinate the conversation content
process in specific conversational
context like therapy sessions and the
counselors have to understand the
patient's intent Behavior even predict
their future behavior in order to apply
corresponding clinical micro skills or
interventions
in classrooms the teachers have to
understand their students behaviors in
order to design conduct educational
activities
in online communities like Reddit and
Wikipedia moderators try to figure out
the intent of the content contributors
to make moderation decisions
in criminal justice systems the judges
have to decide the amount of bail by
weighing the risk of the defendant's
fleeing and not appearing for trials
for thousands of years we as human
beings have developed our skills
expertise procedures methods to
understand and predict each other's
socially relevant behaviors and
oftentimes we use this understandings
and predictions to make important social
decisions
for example the counselor have to decide
whether they want to transfer their
patient to suicidal hotline teachers
have to decide whether they should
intervene to help the students or let
the student explore on their own or the
content moderators decide whether they
should delete the content remove the
account
sorry and these are Judges decide
whether they should detain or release
the defendants
change in the or in the past decade the
field of artificial intelligence AI have
seen striking development and suddenly
we have seen that the ai-based tools
they might be under the name of
intelligent tools risk assessment tool
there's a driven predictive tools and
they are quickly spreading across a
growing range of social decision making
contexts and for example we have seen
that the increasing use of intelligent
Tools in digital mental health support
classrooms all over the world have
started to adopt the intelligent
learning software moderators relying
intelligent tools to moderate content
machine learning based risk assessment
tools are increasingly used in criminal
justice and child welfare systems
and these AI tools come in and trying to
achieve the goal of augmenting our
understanding of the socially relevant
human behaviors and support the decision
making
hi however unlike non-social tasks and
the ground choose in a lot of these
social decision making tasks is that
these the ground choose are actually
socially contested and inherently
uncertain and for example whether there
is actual child abuse or neglect in a
referral cases whether the content is
toxic or not where the patient is
suicidal or not they are often
inherently uncertain due to the
complexity of human behavior and the
complexity of the social circumstances
and human decision makers have already
learned how to operate on the nuance and
unstructured knowledge in corporate
subjective and potentially like
contested values into this high impact
and high stake decision making but it is
unknown how the AI tools are doing in
some of these social decision making
context tasks in real world
so this question actually yeah motivates
like some of my recent work so the first
question I want to answer is how are
these AI tools actually doing in the
real world social decision making
context
how are they used how good are they can
they actually complement and augment our
human decision making
and second question is how can we design
deploy and evaluate Innovative AI tools
that can better support social decision
making
so in today's talk I'm going to share
some of our recent progress and findings
and I'm going to this my talk will be
like two parts and in the first part I'm
going to share our recent study which is
a mixed method post deployment analysis
of the use of a child maltreatment
predictive algorithm used in Allegheny
County Pennsylvania
in the second part of my talk I will
discuss some of our ongoing work on
developing new design methods approaches
and tools to help practitioners
researchers communities to create more
successful AI Innovations in Social
systems
the studies I present today are all
collaboration work with many of my PhD
students undergraduate student Master
students as well as the faculty
collaborators none of the work is
possible without the dedication of the
students and input from The Faculty
collaborators and our work is also
sponsored by National Science
foundation's Amazon Facebook Toyota and
the CMU block Center
so now I'm going to first discuss our
study on the use of the child
maltreatment predicted algorithm in
Allegheny County so because we have
limited time today I will only present
the highlights of the finding and the
detailed findings will be included are
included in this two paper recently
published at Kai 2022 so if you are
interested in learning more details you
can scan the QR code and find the paper
so first so in this study we look at the
a real world context social work where
AI assistant decision making tools are
relatively under discussed yet rapidly
spreading and this is a map from acru in
2021 shows how the new algorithmic Tools
in social work are beginning to spread
across the country and we can look at
the states that are colored green and
yellow the green states are the ones
that are currently using or moving
towards using this kind of algorithmic
machine learning based tools and the
yellow states are ones that have tried
but may decide not to use a tool and in
fact most of these tools that either
currently using being used or like tried
out are inspired by a single tool that
was first deployed in Allegheny County
where Pittsburgh and Cunningham melon
University is and it is called Allegheny
family screening tool tool or afst this
is the tool that we are studying in this
project
so Allegheny County's Department Human
Service deploys FST in 2016 and the afsc
tour assisted social workers in making
screening decisions about the potential
child male treatment cases the tour was
trained on large amounts of government
administrative data
and the FST outputs a prediction on a
scale of 1 to 20 that is meant to
capture the future risk of the children
and specifically it is designed to
predict the future home removal of a
future re-referral
and the score is categorized virtually
into three beans the low risk score like
from one to nine and media risk for
Score 1 to 14 at high risk in the Square
or score that is 15 or above
and the FST is one of the earliest most
well-known and longest deployed AI
assistant decision tool in child welfare
and other public sector agencies have
looked at AFC as a model of what the AI
assisted decision making can also look
like in town welfare so that's why we
think it's critical to study FST now
because we are thinking that we have a
window opportunity maybe to redirect the
trajectory
and this is a like a rough timeline of
how fsp was developed and actually the
county started to collect data of
individuals who received the service
since 24 years ago in 1998 and since
then the agency has started using the
data to make informed decisions often
that time starting by manually searching
the data in 2016 the Allegheny County
agency worked with a few researchers
coming from backgrounds of economic
social work to develop and deploy this
tour FST and we as a group of HCI
researchers were brought in in around
like 2021 and we conducted
post-deployment analysis of FST after
FST was deployed for over five years
and we come in with two questions so
first how do social workers decide
whether when and how much to rely upon
the FST recommendation
and the second question is what are the
decision quality here we measure quality
by the accurate looking at the accuracy
and the racial disparity of the FST
recommendations
to answer these questions we conducted
mixed message research in order to
understand workers daily experience
working with FST we visited the course
screeners and the supervisors in the
actual workplace and we conduct a
contextual inquiry and interviews we
Shadow them as a to course compile case
case reports render FST and make
screening recommendations as they worked
we will occasionally ask questions to
better understand their thought process
and after the observation we conducted
semi-structured post interview with
Revisited moments we observed during the
contextual inquiry and probe deeper into
their underlying beliefs and practices
with using with using the tool
and in total we conducted two fully
filled visits over the course of two
weeks we analyzed data from nine call
screeners and four supervisors including
7 37.5 hours of observation interviews
with 92 pages of observation notes and
9.5 hours of audio recordings
and for the qualitative data analysis we
collected data of the core screening
decisions from 2016 to 2018 and we focus
our analysis on the black white
disparity since these two are the
primary race among the referral cases
and each entry in our data represents a
unique child in a unique referral
now I'm going to share our findings
starting with the coordinated finding
and specifically we identify three
high-level things in our qualitative
analysis each capture a key factor that
guides workers Reliance on the fsp
recommendations
specifically we found that workers
Reliance of FST is Guided by the
perception of the model capabilities and
limitations the organizational pressure
and incentives and also the misalignment
between the algorithmic prediction and
their own decision-making objectives
in the next few slides I'm going to walk
you through like each of these seams
starting from the first one
so we found that the workers form their
beliefs and the perceptions of fst's
capabilities and the limitations
relatively to their own abilities
note that workers in Allegheny County
actually they are intentionally given
minimal information about how the FST
model Works according to the agency
leaderships they told us that they
basically just want to discourage any
gaming Behavior
however the workers because they lack
the like formal training and they tend
to come up with strategy on their own to
learn about the model and for example
they actually play this guessing game
with their colleagues where they would
gamble on what the risk score might be
over time they play this guessing games
with their colleagues and to see like
how far off they were and the workers
that could hone their abilities to
predict the scores
and through this like informal learning
strategies and worker build up their own
sophisticated yet imperfect beliefs and
intuitions about the model's behaviors
and worker uses beliefs and behavior
perceptions to calibrate their Reliance
on the algorithmic recommendation
and specific worker mentioned that they
intentionally adjusted for adversity
limitations by correcting for the
systematic biases in data and Reporting
for example when worker mentioned that
if you are poor and you are welfare you
are going to score higher than a
comparable family who has private
insurance so they actually take this
consideration into their decision making
and second we also fund set the workers
Reliance on the algorithm were
influenced by the organizational
pressure and incentive structure around
the FST
while human Reliance is often discussing
the literature as a matter of trusting
AI but our work is for work to First
work to show that the importance of
considering the organization context in
which the algorithm is deployed
and for example the workers talk about
how their organizations are monitoring
their performance measures and assessing
how frequently they disagree with the
high algorithmic risk scores some
describes as they sometimes agree with a
high risk score against their best
Judgment of in order to avoid being
perceived as disagreeing with afst2 of
it and people describe that they felt
that their expertise as human decision
makers were undervalued given the
decision protocols that actually
discouraged the disagreement with the
algorithmic scores
okay
and finally workers pointed out that
there are fundamental misalignment
between the agrismic prediction and
their own decision-making objectives
and actually the workers what they are
trying to do is to assess the immediate
safety concern but the predictive tools
are trying to predict the long-term risk
they're trained to predict like the
long-term like home removal risk and the
long-term real referral
so these quality defining showed like
hot weather and how much in the people
that rely upon FST recommendation and
when they decided to override the FST
recommendation the next question we ask
is what are the decision quality of the
FST recommendation
and note that in Allegheny County the
FST algorithm only provides
recommendations to the social workers to
the core screeners and their supervisors
and it is their like human workers who
are making the final decision so
therefore when we evaluate the
performance we started the decision
quality of both FSC only and the work
FSC decision here if it's only decision
as a hypothetical decision policy that
automatically screening all the
high-risk cases and screen out all the
moderate and lower skates this is the
case said to simulate what if the
workers basically blindly follow all the
FSC recommendations
and then we also compare that with a
worker FSC decision made by the
co-workers after reviewing the algorithm
recommendations which is a real uh real
decision
and we evaluate the decision against two
metrics and the screening rate and the
accuracy and we look at the screen rate
disparity by looking at how different
the screen this the screen rate is for
black and white children between the FSC
only and the worker FSC decisions and we
also measure the accuracy know that we
made accuracy based on the proxies that
FSC is trained to predict which is a
future referral and other Home placement
uh this is a reminder of the data set we
use this is a two-year call screening
data our data set contains over 51 000
entries on over 33
000 children
this is our overview of our quantitative
finding on the left what you can see is
the screening rate we look at the screen
rate of the FST only decision and work
FSD decisions for black children and for
white children and we compute the
disparity by looking at the difference
on the right we see the accuracy
similarly we look at the accuracy of the
FSC only and worker FST and we look at
the um the accuracy for the black
children or white children and compute
the disparity
so our first finding is that the f is
the only decision would have been more
racially disparate than the worker FSC
Edition
from 2016 to 2018 the FSC only disparity
was 20 because FST only on its own would
have investigated 71 percent of the
black children and 51 percent of the
white children over the same time the
period and same set of cases the workers
the worker disparity was actually nine
percent so the workers actually using
the algorithm reduce the disparity in
the algorithmic recommendation
we want to emphasize that we don't say
that the disparity indicates systematic
racism or whether they are actually
Justified actually there is a a a big
body of literature in Social Work talks
about how to interpret the disparity but
we still want to emphasize that we
believe the disparity especially
disparity in the screening rate is
important because it indicates uneven
level of State interventions into the
white and black children as well as the
uneven distribution of the potential
benefits and harms of interventions
and we also look at the disparity in the
accuracy and we found that the FST was
also more racially dispared in terms of
accuracy and the workers actually use
FST to reduce the disparity
so we see that workers reduce the racial
disparity in the final decision by
disagreeing and overriding the afst
recommendations
but note that remember in the coordinate
finding we found that the workers are
adjusted for FST limitations by
intentionally doing like these
Corrections so this finding is actually
aligned with our coordinated finding
but also note that our these social
workers they made these overriding
decisions under the organization
pressure remember that the organization
actually they are monitoring how often
the workers actually disagree with the
algorithm even sometimes the workers
disagree with the high risk score like
against their best judgment to avoid
being perceived at disagreeing too much
so there are abilities to override these
algorithm Physicians actually was
constrained
so next when we look at just look at the
accuracy overall accuracy we found that
the FSC only screening decisions were
more accurate than the FST workers a
worker decision especially for the white
children
however we also want to highlight the
qualitative finding our quality findings
suggested workers point out there is
fundamental misalignment between the
acrylic prediction and their own
decision-making objectives so note that
the accuracy analysis are based on these
outcomes that are like a FST is trying
to predict so for these outcomes indeed
the FSD is more accurate than human but
actually human sometimes disagree with
the prediction targets of FST
so
um after we
um
after actually our our paper was
accepted and we received additional data
new data and pre-processing instructions
and we rerun all of our quantitative
analysis we actually put up a full
description of the new analysis on
archive so this is the extended QR code
if you are interested so the main
finding remained consistent and robust
to the changes in the data and
pre-processing for example we found that
the FSD only decisions was still more
disparate than worker FST Editions
here is a summary of this finding so in
this finding we conducted a first
in-depth mixed method investigation of
workers current practices and changes in
working with afst
overall we found that although FST has
been used for nearly half a decade the
system remained a source of attention
for many workers and as it is this right
now we believe FST still is a missed
opportunities to effectively complement
Frontline workers decision-making
abilities
specifically there is a misalignment
between the system goals and the workers
objectives and values and there is a
lack of formal training and real-time
interface support to help the Frontline
workers to understand and work with the
FST recommendations there is a lack of
organizational support to empower the
workers to override the erroneous and
biased ifst recommendations
so know that yeah we were brought in
like just 2021 so we noticed that there
are this limitation of the FST and if we
could go back in time what we could do
how we can do in order to make it right
and this leads to the second part of my
talk and which is some of our ongoing
work of developing new design methods
approaches and tools to help
practitioners researchers communities to
create the more successful Innovations
and maybe make the afst or FST similar
like tools to be more successful
now here I'm going to present three
studies that actually focus on
addressing the value misalignment in the
FST case we see misalignment between the
system goal and workers objectives and
values but we also find that this is not
an isolated case this is not just open
like this is not just a problem with FST
an interview study with 27 public sector
machine learning practitioner across 500
countries actually shows that there is a
like a general pattern of a disconnect
of the design of existing machine
Learning System and the community
stakeholders values realities and
contexts so today I'm going to discuss
maybe briefly these three paper and
these papers are all like aimed at like
address the value misalignment and these
are the work we published at Kai 2020
this 2021 and fact this year 2022.
so uh in the paper we're publishing uh
at CCW 2018 we propose a bottom up
design method we call the value
sensitive algorithm design to address
value misalignment which we propose that
we should start by conceptualizing the
community stakeholders value and then
use that understanding to guide the
design choices of algorithms so the
first step is to understand the
stakeholder value and then explain the
value trade-off make the trade-off
interpretable and third step is to
navigate the value trade-off and make
design and design decisions
and we apply this method in the context
of Wikipedia we all know what Wikipedia
is it is the largest online free
encyclopedia
and actually the quality control is one
of the major tasks faced by the
Wikipedia Community for example for
English Wikipedia alone every day they
receive a 160 000 edits and they're all
immediate go live so Wikipedia are
facing the challenges to like monitor
these large volumes of incoming edits so
Wikipedia has developed this system
called objective revision evasion system
or auris and orus is a machine learning
based predictive tool and they are
designed to predict the added quality
like where this given edit is damaging
or not and the editor intent with this
editor this contributor is good face or
bad face
uh these predictions is have already
been ours prediction have already been
Incorporated in the recent changes on
the main Wikipedia interface and hacker
which is a Content moderation tool used
by many reviewers of Wikipedia like a
Content portrayal of Wikipedia and they
are also incorporating more than 30
different applications
in our study we're trying to apply the
value sensitive algorithm design to
redesign the Wikipedia's Aura system so
first we're trying to understand the
Wikipedia stakeholders value and then we
explain and the design system
interactive system to explain and
visualize the value trade-off and the
third step we engage community members
in the discussion and deliberation as a
value trade-off and make a decision
so for the for the first step we yeah
conducted interviews to understand the
Wikipedia stakeholders values
we interviewed 16 relevant Wikipedia
stakeholders they are always creator
to two developers who created tools
based on the RS predictions
and the four members from the Wikimedia
product team
seven regular editors and two
researchers who study Wikipedia
we ask questions like yes
I've heard my users of Wikipedia are not
part of the community of stakeholders
yes that's a very good point yes so in
this study we didn't directly interview
users because a lot of users they might
not like understand what is actually
going on like in the editing but also
note that most of the people that hold
like new roles and these are people they
are doing working to contribute content
to Wikipedia they're also consuming the
content like everyone here yeah we are
like consuming content so but you're
right we did not expressly like
interview people who are only the
readers of the Wikipedia
any other questions
okay so the then the questions we ask
people are like their roles on Wikipedia
the experience related to others where
they are using like building tools for
us or they are impacted by owners we ask
their opinions and also ideas for future
we conducted the Grande Theory method
approach we analyze and code every line
of interview transcripts conducted like
group meetings to custom codes discard
the indirect iterate on the themes
and we identify seven seams or seven
like values from our qualitative
analysis there are two greater values
and five convergent Community Values
again because we have limited time so
this is the list of the convergence
Community value and I'm going to
highlight the two values so one is the
effort reduction and the other one is a
positive engagement
the effort reduction is about reducing
the effort of community maintenance
and people told that it's really
important for communities to like save
the like the maintenance effort for
example one developer told us that if we
can Leverage The Manpower that we do
have with more automation these people
will have less backlog and can focus on
other contributions
another important value is positive
engage engagement which is about
encouraging positive engagement with
diverse editor groups
for example one researcher told us that
I think the article quality is driven to
a large extent by the diversity of the
hundreds of users
and um when we can media Foundation
employee actually told us that the
current ecosystem of Wikipedia limits
the diversity of the contributors so the
ecosystem needs to change in order to be
more welcoming to certain kinds of
people
however when we're trying to map these
Community Values into the actual system
criteria and we found like that these
are like trade-off inherent trade-offs
for example if we want to like aim at
like maximizing effort reduction then
the system criteria corresponding system
criteria including that we want to
maximizing the overall accuracy we want
to minimizing the force negative rate
in contrast if we want to like aim at
like promoting the positive engagement
with the diverse editor groups then we
should try to minimize the first party
rate and also make sure to minimize
minimize the disparity between the model
performance on the different other
groups now however these criterias are
not compatible you cannot like
simultaneously like achieve all these
criteria and there is like inherent
trade-off between this system criterias
so for the second step we designed
interactive variation system to explain
and viralize this value trade-off
and we created this tool called RS
Explorer which contains a set of
visualizations to help application
designers and community members to
understand the inherent trade-offs in
Wikipedia RS system
so our system contains multiple
interfaces the first one is a landing
page where we provide the basic overview
of the RS system how the RS scores like
works and how the hours making
predictions and we also explain some of
the fundamental machine learning
Concepts and how that like a
corresponder represents different
Community Values and we in this way our
users will have the necessary knowledge
to explore the realizations that comes
next step
and we create this interface called
threshold Explorer and this interface
allowed people to explore different
threshold settings and the inherent
trade-off associated with setting
different thresholds
so for example if the threshold is set
to 0.5 and it is Will scores above 0.5
will be predicted as damaging and this
Explorer interface allows users to play
with a threshold setting
and we also have this group disparity
viralizer which allows users to see and
compare the model performance on the
different groups and for the different
models with different thresholds and in
terms of the looking at or compare
different evaluation metrics
and we also have this threshold
recommender interface here we allow the
users to just choose their goals and
preferences and then we automatically
like recommend the threshold according
to their preferences and goals and but
we also allow users to adjust the
Justice threshold and continue to play
based on the recommended threshold yeah
yeah very good question so here we are
probably looking at the anonymous at a
group and identify the editor group and
we offer the identify as a group we all
people can also look into like newcomers
and experience the editors because there
are already literatures in the looking
study or Wikipedia and the funds that
they're like systematic bias against
like newcomers sometimes the newcomers
they are like their edits are much more
easily to be reverted and marked as
damaging compared to experienced editor
and so are the anonymous editors so here
we want to like a look at actually the
um the disparity across Anonymous
newcomers and experience editors we also
want to look at other attributes for
example demographic informations male
female for example of the editors we
also know that there is a huge gender
gap in the header base and have a
systematic circle on gender however we
don't have data that about people's
gender
media not collector yes
right right right right right but in
some of the previous like surveys people
posted researchers posted they found
that over 90 of waiters are male 10
percent of the editor less than 10
percent of editors are female but yeah
Wikipedia because Wikipedia does not
collect demographic data so we don't
have the demographic data research
showing how
the diversity of Wikipedia the
wikipedians or whatever you call them is
has not led to any change in collecting
yeah it doesn't lead to any changes in
that practice and they do have to
considering maybe like also the privacy
of the people and yeah but yeah the the
short answer is that didn't change how
uh data collection
so
yeah so uh we we did some evaluation
with this like an interactive system and
found that this system could are very
effective in helping people who do not
have machine learning background to
understand the important inherent
trade-offs in our system
and then in the third step we present
this system to the community members and
engage the community members in the
discussion of this value trade-off
so we combine the visualizations with
the community deliberation workshops and
the goal is to explain the tensions
value attentions to the community
members and engage them to resolve the
tensions between the different Community
Values we conducted our workshops in two
Wikipedia language Community one Dutch
community and the English would be
English Wikipedia community
um we designed our deliberation protocol
like this so first the participants have
to like complete the pre-survey and then
the participants will individually
explore the RS Explorer interface pick a
model and they can export a model card
and after this individual exploration
phase we uh we put the people together
and ask people to conduct and to to
start a discussion then they can discuss
like the uh the the models different
individuals picked and discuss the pros
and cons of the different models and
what is the best for the community they
can also go back to the RS Explorer
interface and to find a different model
and after that we asked our participants
to write a proposal into either pick a
model or they can say that oh we don't
want any model
after that we like completed a post
survey so this is the interface we
developed to further facilitate the
group deliberation and here we allow our
users on the base of the orus basic
interface we also create this model
called also authoring interface and
people can export export any model and
generate a model card which has a like
concise summary of the model performance
and how that impacts the different
Community stakeholders
so in summary this series of work we
believe contribute to the HCI and AI
communities and we believe that our
study contributes first a broad
understanding of the human values
related to the AI based predictive Tools
in online communities we also designed
this like normal approaches and and
supporting toolkits that can facilitate
Greater Community Control and agency and
leads to the creation of AI tools that
are more aligned with the Community
Values
and this work has direct implications on
the Improvement of Wikipedia hours as
well as a broader implication of the
design of AI Tools in other online or
offline community contexts
so now I'm going to use the final few
slides to share some of our ongoing work
that happening in my lab at a high level
and we conduct like both a discovery
type of work trying to understand the
impact of AI tools how people use these
AI tools and in Social systems we also
contact design type of work trying to
create like new message approaches and
toolkits
and specifically we conduct research in
multiple domains and one of the
important domain we will look at is the
online mental health support and people
with mental health problems are
increasingly turning to online peer
support communities for help instead of
Professional Services and because it's
peer support services much cheaper and
more accessible we actually partner with
sevencups.com which is one of the
largest online peer-to-peer mental
health support community in the world
and we started to use and design of
various AI Tools in this context such as
aggressive matching system the suicidal
prediction system and the chapel-based
training environment and to the goal is
to create a better peer support
environment and my student NFL Logan
staple Stapleton and windy young are
working in this domain
I also study git work at git platforms
and the whole gig economy ecosystem
focusing on designing intelligence
decision support tools to empower and
encountering workers and this is a part
of a larger NSF project involving four
different institutions my student Jane
is working actively in this direction
and Beyond FST and decision support
Tools in child welfare we also worked on
the AI using Housing Services and
Building Services in Allegheny County
and the City of Pittsburgh
and we will also continue to work on
like our online content moderation and
in the Wikipedia context and my students
working on this
and we have the intelligent learning
software in classroom we're also
starting intelligent learning software
in classroom and my student Naomi is
really interested in understanding how
these tools are actually used in
classroom especially for students with
different types of learning disabilities
we as a lab also believe that not every
problem in social system could be or
should be resolved by AI so we are also
exploring a lot of non-ai-based
solutions and for example my student
Jordan and Syria are interested in
looking at the online infrastructure
data infrastructure for example Jordan
user infrastructure lens to study the
social media use for marginalized groups
and we're also exploring low-tech and
no-tech Innovations in the context of
child welfare and Logan has started
conducted this interesting like
Community Workshop to explore a lot of
like a low-tech and low-tech
alternatives
and Anna is working on developing like
new deliberation process and protocol
around whether or not the design and the
use of a public sector AI tool is
Justified
and Jay is working on like uh using like
speed dating as a method to explore the
white space of service and policy
Innovations to promote the gig worker
well-being
so this is uh I believe all the slides I
have and thank you everyone and for yeah
listening to my talk and I'm happy to
take any question
[Applause]
yeah
I'm curious especially on when you're
looking for the child versus assessment
how is the model looking at the kind of
relative failure of classifying ton of
breasts when they weren't at risk versus
not caused by risk when they were at
risk because it seems like those
failures aren't necessarily equal in
terms of potential impact so I'm curious
whether or not there's any analysis of
if for example the human workers had
higher failure rates in one area than no
Gene in the other area
yeah yeah that's a very good questions
uh yeah you're completely right so
different kind of Errors actually have a
different kind of impact and both like
errors like is a false positive or false
negative that's very like important
societal consequences so in the current
analysis I present we didn't explicitly
explore we look at the overall accuracy
but some of uh like a work conducted by
also PhD students in HCI like look and
he's trying to look at like what kinds
of the errors that the FSC is making and
what kind of error like the human is
making and then trying to see that if
there is a pattern and as a way to see
what we could do to better like
complement the like the human like
abilities and the Machine learning
capabilities so that's a great question
that's also some areas that we are
exploring
foreign
so I remember you mentioned like uh one
interesting point that these social
workers sometimes their objectives are
different from the tools objective and
I'm wondering if you could elaborate
more out there like what kind of papers
Did You observe and because you also
took a new approaches and tools to
address these problems do you have any
thoughts about what kind of tool or
novel design approaches can be used to
right right yeah that's a very good
question so let me pull up the slides
and what we found basically is yeah the
workers they are trying to assess the
immediate safety concerns so they will
focus on the case itself looking at the
allegations and trying to figure out
where this particular kit is in any
immediate risk and safety like risks but
the tool what it does basically train on
historical data and it's actually
predicting a future risk so there is
this misalignment between this and then
a lot of workers sometimes they override
the tool because they believe that oh
this kid is not in immediate like Risk
although it's flagged at high risk by
the uh by FST so what we see to address
this issue is uh this is something uh my
student Anna is interesting doing and
she's trying to maybe uh one of the
things she's trying to explore is how we
can co-design a co-design with the
Frontline workers of what is the right
thing to predict so what is the right
protection Target and so we believe that
if we could do that and then that will
like address this like a misalignment
between the like prediction targets and
the actual like the work objectives
still
um thanks so much uh again on the um the
the first part the Allegheny County uh
system
um given that it's being employed or
being looked at in so many different
areas and given that uh
the the data shows that there is this
sort of misalignment and there is this
disparity in it
um
what do you think is sort of the next
step for the tool I mean do should
should institutions scrap it completely
should they rework it should they rework
how it's being implemented or being
supported by the institution I'm curious
like how how you see
um the the development of it in the
future given what you know now about it
hey uh it's a great question I have a
lot to say
since maybe I cannot say here I'm happy
to share with you offline happy to share
with people there are a lot of
interesting story actually some of the
interesting follow-up with FST but I
will say that yeah our FST work was
picked up and reported by a lot of like
media uh like the journalists and they
got like a covered in different media
articles and actual Oregon State and
they use a tool that actually models FST
and after seeing the like media coverage
and also yeah our uh research papers
they decide to drop their tool and they
are actually exploring like a different
alternative process to improve the core
screening instead of relying on like
automatic tools and we present our like
a design like recommendations to
Allegheny County including the changes
and in the model itself the interface
and training as well as the organization
potential organizational like changes
but yeah it's there are some interesting
story behind it yeah and happy to share
more offline Maybe
hi
um I think in both parts of your talk I
felt like I kind of saw this thread that
I was picking up on so like in the first
part you were talking about how with um
FSC like a lot of the workers were
basically assessing how well
um this uh prediction system was working
and then even with the ores on part
um there were
um I guess users or editors they were
trying to basically translate their own
ideas into like what models would look
like and I feel like in both of these
um Parts it's really feeling like we as
people have to kind of learn about
machine learning more and it doesn't
seem like it's really like
um people who are developing these
systems are actually learning about what
works best so are there like do you know
of any people that have kind of done
work and like from like I guess more of
like the AI side trying to be like from
at the beginning not just after like
this analysis what are we going to
actually build in or think about in
terms of like
um talking about how people are going to
use these systems right that's a great
great question so we propose that we
should actually the other like tool and
these algorithm Developers
should like talk to stakeholders and
learn about stakeholders and then learn
about their needs and their their
objectives their values in the very
beginning and incorporate that in the
design process so for the second part so
we are proposing actually the hour we
are working with the Wikipedia and there
are like the RS Creator actually to
redesign and the others so we are
applying this approach like starting
with understanding all the stakeholders
values and then trying to figure out how
this value mapped to the different
system criteria and then navigate the
trade-off and then eventually allow the
community members and then the
application developers to make informed
decisions on like which model the
community should use and which model
their application should use so this is
the approach that we want to maybe
Advocate that all the system developers
should use so they should use actually
the very basic human Center design
in our in the design and the creation of
any AI system especially this AI systems
that are deployed in complicated
complicated social context and will it
have like this like a lot of impact on
people so this is what we want to argue
for and then yeah and to what extent
like the practitioners will be actually
influenced and use this approach we
don't know we are trying maybe this
disseminine our work but on the other
hand we see that on industry and they
are also concerned about like ethics
Faith related issues we have seen some
very interesting initiatives also coming
from industry coming from Microsoft one
coming from Google Etc so we do think
that there is a shared interest that
both foreign
industry to improve the process of
creating AI tools
foreign
yeah I guess I was wondering like it
seemed like um with the comparison of
the just afst alone versus with worker
assistance it seems like the poor thing
getting pulled out there is like the
importance of this discretion that these
workers are taking I was wondering like
um because I was wondering whether the
disparity like was a good thing or a bad
thing and like beginning that we don't
know what the base weights of like
occurrence are and sorry this is a long
winter but I guess I was just wondering
how you what you think about how we
should think about discretion and
whether it's going in a good or bad
Direction
um because it seemed like part of the
work on the um where you're highlighting
the misalignment of metrics was working
or
um I guess pushing for a direction of
maybe like going and measuring that new
thing that is aligned with the workers
um goals but do you think that there'll
always be some amount of discretion that
is not able to be measured and
um yeah I guess what do you think about
how we should reason about that
since you are talking about that
disparity or you're talking about the
the difference between the prediction
targets and the actual human objects I
think I was kind of talking a bit about
both okay but the disparity I guess it
highlighted the fact that there is an
important sway in workers having that
discretion and then however the
misalignment
um
basically like I think that ties into
the discussion as well because like
ideally they would be able to
um build off of their perception of what
should be in the model
but do you think we should just build
models that mimic the person's
discretion or I guess what do you think
about that balance okay yeah yeah that's
a very good question so first of all
about the disparity between the
different racial groups so uh actually
we also calculated the pre-fst disparity
level which is 11.3 through January 2015
to July 2016. so
um however we want to like emphasize
down the pre-fsp like stages might not
be directly comparable to the policy FST
because we do not know if I create a
difference from 11.3 percent to nine
percent is actually uh should be
attributed to the introduction of FST
because there are different cases pre
and post they actually also have like a
policy changes around the time so but
yeah but on the other hand we do see
that the worker actually reduces
disparity sort of back to the pre-fst
stages but the FSC alone has a disparity
like 20 in terms in terms of how to
interpret the disparity so we still
believe that disparity will indicate the
uneven distribution of the potential
benefits and the harms of the state
interventions so like the 20 maybe it's
still alarming although we don't have
any evidence suggesting that it's
actually Justified or unjustified
um and it's really a systematic reason
or not so what we are actually claiming
that there are the workers they were
able to like reduce the disparity to
like nine percent almost like equivalent
to the pre-fsp
um stages so but yeah it's a very uh
it's a long a large body of literature
in social work talking about how you we
should interpret the for example
disparity in screen rate
um and back to the yeah your second
questions about the yeah the
misalignment sorry if I uh let me see if
I can find it yeah misalignment between
the prediction targets and the people's
like decision making like um like yeah
decision making targets so yeah I think
this is the whole area we want to
explore that the weather we want to have
the tools just to mimic human decisions
or actually the the tools should be
predict something else but we should
train people to work with like these
different predictions and then actually
work with different predictions in order
to like actually enhance the overall
decision quality and I believe it's
still an open question and the things I
mentioned earlier is about like
co-design is like one steps we want to
do to explore the space is basically
yeah what to design what to predict and
what is the best way we could do to
complement
um yeah into augment human abilities in
this decision making tasks
foreign
unless you were mentioning that there
was some fear about gaming the system
and that was the reason that these
workers weren't like told how it worked
and that's pretty in contrast to the
second project you were talking about
where this was all about trying to help
the people who were using the system
understands what the predictions were
and weren't saying
um so kind of two-part question what was
the behavior that the people the playing
the system were afraid about in terms of
gaming like what did they think the
employees would do and why was that
undesirable and then if you feel
comfortable commenting on whether you
think that's a good decision to like
basically prevent the people using the
system from understanding how it works
yeah so yeah this is very very good
questions yeah I can also pull out the
slides about the like a guessing games
right so uh as I mentioned the the
agency they basically just tell people
that oh we want to just show people how
or show our own workers our own social
workers how this system works they are
maybe afraid that they will get really
somehow released and then maybe even
malicious maybe people might manipulate
to the school and may manipulate the
um given that it's very it's influenced
some very high stake decisions and
whether yeah they might be afraid of the
the minutiae people will take advantages
of the this transparency of the kind of
system or algorithm and that's their
concern however what we show is like
yeah even if you do not tell the workers
the worker will figure out they have to
figure out in order to like incorporate
this FST like recommendations into that
decision making but this is also an
interesting space is that a potential
interest space to explore could we agree
on one hand maybe uh yeah protect from
practice from any like a malicious sort
of attacks but also or like actually
helps workers actually to work with
these kind of algorithmic
recommendations
um yeah so I don't know if I answer your
question
all right I'll close it out with one
last one
um you
made a claim near the end of the talk
that these approaches can create
outcomes that are more aligned with the
Community Values
which aspirational is a goal I totally
agree with
and I think I just want to unpack that a
little bit and say like well whose goals
are the community goals
and how would we know if they're
actually more aligned like when do we
get to declare success here right right
yeah that's a great question uh so what
we claim is like yeah it's the
everything related to yeah actually uh
socially relevant the human behaviors is
complicated so it's actually yeah like I
mentioned at the very beginning so what
we could do is just like making some
progress in terms of understanding yeah
what is actually the community like
goals are and I will argue that we
should do that in the as a first step so
for the Wikipedia Case aura's Case so
what we do is like we first ask people
what do you think the orus system should
achieve and what is your important
Community goals so that's actually the
what is the important Community value we
call it value but value is actually a
generic reward we use it's indicating
anything that's important to the
communities and then we did this
correlative work and trying to sing
synthesize what people have been telling
us and then come up with this like five
things we believe that oh these are the
things that the system should achieve
and then we do the mapping to the uh to
the actual system criteria and and
eventually we we want to let the
community members to decide whether they
feel like yeah after exploring and
knowing how systems work they think that
at least they they see a acceptable
trade-off sort of is achieved in the in
the system as a sort of success so
um and yeah let me see so but I think
what this is sort of is This reducing to
a social Choice question at some level
like who gets to make that decision
about which trade-off actually
represents the community right and you
know and who has the power to make that
decision which is a really tough thing
right right I agree yeah I agree yeah
that's extremely tough so uh we trying
to like sort of for all for all of these
study sort of we post it on the like
open forums on Wikipedia basically
anyone can comment for the first study
everyone like can can join and then we
show these five like uh like values also
like uh we will we present the five
value back to the online Forum so
Wikipedia and we want to engage any
people to comment on like do you think
these are the things you agree on so
that's one of our like attempts trying
to expand the maybe the the audience
that was trying to engage as many people
as possible in the discussion but still
yeah eventually it will be the really
active peoples who have more say and
then who are willing to come in to
participate in this willing to engage in
the discussion willing to like a vote
and eventually like a influence the
decision maybe that's just the same for
our any like democracy system so and
like the people who are willing to vote
actually will influence all right
computer science is Political Science
excellent let's I'll thank our speaker
thank you for joining us
thank you thank you for having me